and all I do is hold my breath and then
cry after she's finished and squeeze
somebody oh my gosh yes and yes you hear
people saying just how how great your
daughter is but I mean Simone Estelle
Simone and my daughter so I don't see
her or put her on a pedestal
just to do the dishes so if it's her
turn
yes she needs to get out of bed and get
over there and do the dishes one time we
are going out to dinner and we walked
out of our rooms like wail exact same
out so we're like whoo it was like a who
wore it better ward miss I mean
obviously like someone has to go change
and it's not gonna be me so we just went
to dinner where this is me and it was
not until 2013 when she won the world
competition it was a very special moment
I remember crying and crying yes it like
made me tear up um cuz like on the big
screen in the arena they said my parents
and I've never really seen my mom cry or
like my dad cat and they were sobbing up
there and I was so cute and it just like
made me feel so accomplished that
they're just so proud of you that they
cried
and use the world just because she's
like gone in and out of loops for me and
she'll do anything she's giving up so
much and sacrifice so much for me to
achieve the things that I've achieved
and it is amazing what she does and what
mom's with you
I am absolutely proud of my daughter